[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
mini kasparov saga we are back at the
creation granchester it's the second day
of the blitz section and it's kasparov
with the white pieces against his
nemesis from round one of yesterday
jordan
and i've decided to pronounce him only
as jordan for the time being because it
seems like
uh well just pronouncing his actual uh
last name is impossible uh i've tried it
and some of you actually were kind
enough to send me
uh you know proper ways of pronouncing
this but even
uh three of you have sent me this and
all three pronunciations were different
and uh one of you uh even sent me
uh an original video where jordan
pronounces it himself and
uh that that pronunciation is pure
sorcery i cannot pronounce that like uh
half of the letters are silent and you
know this is this is one name where i
give up for the moment i i am planning
on learning it and i will improve but
for the moment
he will only be referred to as the
jordan so it's garrick aspara versus the
jordan and it's uh the first game of the
second day of the blitz it's quite the
game uh kasparov had a terrible game a
terrible
day yesterday out of the nine games he
only got one draw against alexander
grishok
and he lost all the other eight games
and now uh well we'll see if
his bad luck will continue will this be
officially his worst tournament ever
or will he bounce back so here with the
white pieces kasparov
opens with e4 we have e5 and kasparov
goes for his uh long lost weapon and
that is of course the scotch so knight
to f3 knight to c6
and d4 uh the scotch game we have e
captus and e4
knight captures in the knight to f6 now
the schmidt variation of the scotch
we have knight captures on c6 b captures
and e5 now so this is very well known
there are thousands of games in the
database with this exact same line
uh queen to e7 now of course uh pinning
the spawn and the queen to e2 now the
thread
thread of course is just capturing this
knight so knight to d5
and c4 and kasparov himself has many
games in the database with this exact
same line
and usually what black will do here is
either uh retreat with the knight with
knight to b6 or even pin the pawn with
bishop to a6 so you can't capture the
knight but here
uh jordan goes for a different line he
plays queen to b for with chick saying
that okay kasparov uh
and i forgot to play queen to be for
check against mommy or yesterday
uh i'm gonna play it now and see see
what happens so here queen to be for
check again it's not a new move but it's
a very very
rare one so here it knights the d2
kasparov defense and now
knight to f4 with an attack on the queen
we have queen to e3
and now knight the g6 so it's a bit
different than all the other lines
uh that we were used to seeing in this
uh particular variation
uh because usually this knight ends up
on b6 not on g6 so let's see how gary
deals with this we have bishop to d3
he of course just continues development
and now bishop to c5
developing with tempo uh the queen
retreats the g3 and now both players
just castle so castles castles and
now d6 attacking this pawn here uh
and uh saying what are you gonna do here
so while kasparov could defend it he
could even decide to give up the bishop
for night here but that's something
kasparov can never do
uh he's a natural attacker and of course
he wants his bishops pair to be fully
operational at all cost
so here there is one game in the
database where e captures and b6 was
played
but here kasparov just plays knight to
b3 he prepares to develop his other
bishop
and he says okay you can have your pawn
i'm gonna grab your bishop so i'm gonna
be the one with the bishop pair
and i'm gonna try and attack your king
so here jordan accepts the challenge and
he goes for knight characters on e5 with
a3 first
uh pushing the queen back queen to b6
and now
knight captures on c5 we have queen
captures and now
bishop to e3 going for some rapid
development here so only one move for
the black queen that's queen to a5 and
now kasparov continues advancing with b4
so kasparov is down upon but he's the
one dictating the tone of the battle
so queen to a4 and now bishop to d4
making it impossible for black to
eliminate this very strong light square
bishop
as you would get checkmated here on g7
uh and there is also another problem if
you don't do anything f4 is coming
you're going to have to give up the
knight otherwise you're again getting
checkmated
so here manaforest goes for the absolute
strongest defensive idea and that is f6
yes sometimes that is the
the absolute strongest idea and now
kasparov has to figure out how to uh
get past this monster knight on e5 so
now he says all right
i know this is uh really a problem for
me now and the f6 pawn
really numbs down the power of my bishop
so i'm just going to give up the bishop
for knight here
and then take advantage of your lack of
development to maybe
do some damage so here f captures on e5
and now f4
trying to open up the position before
forrest can develop
his before jordan can develop his pieces
so here uh and yeah i've tried to master
it but it is you know some of you say
it's a foray
somehow you say it's four iced for east
it's um
you know i will improve uh so jordan
here
uh after f4 plays bishop to f5 he
continues development and now
f captures on e5 we have bishop captures
on d3
because power captures on d3 and now d
captures on e5 so for the moment
you can see that the material is now
equal or oh
sorry black is still up upon but now
queen to d7 by kasparov
and now that's a very active square for
the queen you're attacking c7
and jordan has to decide what to do here
so he could
try to grab a pawn but it doesn't really
work for example captures captures and
now
uh what do you do if you capture an a3
well queen to f7 check and it's black
who's getting checked maybe you just
give up the queen
and that's it black gets checkmated so
you can't really go all greedy here
so queen to b3 now putting pressure on
c4 but also just trying to remaneuver
the queen back into the game via a queen
to e3 check
so here kasparov grabs the pawn on c6
and now we have queen the e3 check king
to h1
and one forest uh again i i do it uh
goes king to h8 uh we have rook f the e1
going after the queen here queen to c3
and now queen captures on c7 so grabbing
yet another pawn
but jordan of course is playing to bring
the rook in and pick up this pawn
so rook ate the c8 and now queen
captures an
a7 grabbing yet another pawn rook
captures on c4 and
now h3 kasparov creates some breeding
room for the king here
and rook c to f4 now nicely doubling up
on the f file
uh his e5 pawn is protected so maybe you
can start advancing it
and kasparov will try of course to
advance his queen side pawns to see who
is faster but for the moment kasparov is
up upon
and uh things are looking very very good
for him uh we have queen to c5
gary immediately goes for the queen
trade uh and jordan of course
declines this we have queen back to b2
and now kasparov
grabs the pawn here uh wanting to uh
trade the queens
of the board because now he's up two
pawns and you know it's just gonna be
good for him but again
uh jordan has to decline this he plays
queen to b3
and here the position is completely
winning for gary of course he's
up two pawns uh but there's one a very
efficient way to end the game
so feel free to pause the video here and
win the game for gary
the quickest way possible while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on playing pretty
much anything you can play rook to b1
start advancing the pawn you can push
the pawn to b5 immediately but the
quickest way to win this is just to
capture the rook and that's it of course
black's the weakness of the back rank is
uh very much present here because if the
rook captures the queen now
just rook to e8 to check and that's it
we could also give up the rook first but
you have to play queen here
and then captures captures and then of
course it's uh just two pawns up to
connect it
past spawns up this is completely
winning for white but both of them are
extremely low on time this is a blitz
game and instead of this kasparov just
plays queen to e3
uh so what does he want here he wants to
trade queens now and then uh
use the both of the rooks probably place
this rook on b1 and then just advance
both of his pawns
uh with uh so so little time on the
clock this seems to be
uh the more straightforward way but uh
leaving the queens on the board maybe
not be
maybe isn't so great but okay queen to
c4 and now
rook eight the c1 chasing his queen
queen back to f7 now tripling here on
the f file
and now queen to g3 now uh if if this
rook for example ever moves you can
always play some like rook here and then
put some pressure on the g
file uh but it's uh you know uh
anything is possible but basically
sparta's plan is just to advance his
queen side pawn so here we have h6
uh one first uh also i i do it again
jordan uh uh also creates some breeding
room for his king
and kasparov starts advancing his past
pawn so b5
we have queen to d5 and now a4 so even
offering this spawn just to
discoordinate
black strokes a little bit uh jordan
grabs the pawn rook captures an a4 but
now just rook to b1 and this pawn is now
a monster as it's protected by a rook
so rook to f5 and now comes a b6 just
continuing to push that pass pawn
we have rook to g5 putting some pressure
here on the on the g
pawn but now just b7 and here kasparov
says okay that's it
uh if you capture my queen i'm just
going to bring another queen into the
game and pick up the rook and i'm going
to be upper rook king h7 queen captures
on g3
and of course i win here so instead
after this b7 move
we have queen captures on b7 by jordan
and now comes queen captures on g5 and
it was in this position that jordan
resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so after nine rounds
tenth round goes to gary kasparov he
retaliates for his loss to jordan
uh in the first round it was a really
really uh you know nice 25 move
brilliancy but now he bounces back and
we'll see
if this is the first of many victories
of the beast with a thousand eyes or if
this is just uh you know
one one out of uh uh one out of uh and
eighteen
uh so here of course you resign because
there is nothing for you to do if you
capture the queen we're just going to
capture this queen and now we're up a
whole rook and other than that you
really don't have a move um
if you try and do something like queen
captures here we're just going to play
queen to d8 to check
or anything here i mean there's really
there's nothing
we we can't do queen to d8 to check king
to h7 and now we're just going to play
rook captures on b1 so we just move our
queen away from danger and we're up a
full queen
uh so uh that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh like i said after queen
captures on
uh g5 uh jordan resigned the game and uh
this is the first
victory for gary kasparov in this blitz
section of the creation granchester
and also sorry about mispronouncing
jordan's last name so many times in this
video
so yeah once again hope you guys enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank kevin keith
robert aratone and jim alboyd and
cruzada.com for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this mini
caspar of saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day